em 2009 eu entrei no curso de economia
porque eu queria me transformar o mundo
quem essa idéia de criar um plano
econômico mirabolante que você impactar
o maior número de pessoas possíveis numa
comunidade carente seja no brasil seja
na áfrica seja onde for essa coisa do
sonhador de 19 anos oito anos a limpo
falando um pouquinho na história falando
porque uns dois três anos pra frente eu
me largar no discurso de economia quase
no finalzinho por isso o economista a
gente deixa ele é e abrindo o meu
próprio estúdio de design
então aquilo que estava projetando
naquele momento nunca e atingir um
grande número de pessoas
minha idéia era trabalhar localmente
seja é com as pessoas que estavam ao
redor ou seja com as pessoas inclusive
com que a gente ia se relacionar em
termos de venda de produto ao longo do
primeiro ano inteiro foi aquele conflito
largando mão de algo que eu sei que eu
possa impactar quantitativamente uma uma
infinidade de pessoas e tem algo que
pontos sendo o dono da minha própria
empresa que é algo que eu sempre
recriminei quando estava economia banco
empresas grandes era algo que eu fugi
assim completamente mas bem à medida que
as pessoas que eu fui eu que caçando
amigos e amigos de amigos por lá no
estúdio gente meio que as relações de
trabalho foram se formando dessa maneira
à medida que fui conhecendo esse pessoal
para trabalhar junto
eu fui percebendo que talvez não tivesse
ele impactam uma quantidade tão grande
de pessoas
mas a maneira com que eu estava
impactado pelo num simples jeito de ser
aqueles que estavam ao meu redor era
infinitamente maior do que aquele plano
econômico do que eu imaginava com 19
anos impactar um ser humano que está
perto de você vai muito além daquela
relação de trabalho que você é você cria
com ele você começa a perceber que suas
atitudes do dia a dia
elas saem dessa esfera é do trabalho
principalmente quando você quer criar
alguma coisa que não tem hierarquia
nenhuma se trabalha com pessoas que não
chegaram em faculdades que não tiveram
oportunidade se trabalha com pessoas
mais novas que você já tem três filhos
para criar
você trabalha com pessoas que não
terminaram colégio e aí todo dia que
chega no estúdio super felizes e tomou
um tapa na cara porque você meio que vai
aprendendo muito com essas pessoas o que
é realmente é é o mundo real devemos
assim meu primeiro tapa na cara nessa
brincadeira e aí o aprendizado que eu
tive deles e que provavelmente a pessoa
com quem essa situação aconteceu não faz
a menor idéia de que aquele dia mudou
minha vida foi o dia que eu via tinha
saindo do estúdio é uma das pessoas que
trabalha com a gente com uma marmita na
mão eu falei pô tinha porque senão vai
mostrar com a gente
ela vira pra mim falar porque guardar
sua marmita para dividir com meus filhos
à noite de jantar já nunca tinha passado
pela minha cabeça naquele momento
obviamente que eu saí dali fui direto
para o banheiro daquela chorado absurda
levantei falei cara pelo menos aquilo
que está fazendo todo santo dia
está realmente mudando um pouquinho que
seja a vida de quinta do meu lado
daquele dia em diante ela obviamente
tirava as marmitas no dia para levar a
um ataque dela como dj
eu comecei a perceber que independente
do dinheiro que gira em torno da sua
idéia se você lastrear qualquer idéia de
empreender qualquer ideia de negócio se
sua motivação realmente for financeira
século 21 se estão fadados a morrer de
verdade sim a motivação de hoje em dia e
principalmente da turma que está sentada
aqui com a proposta de absorver
conhecimento das mais variadas pessoas
que estão passando pelo ted é justamente
fazer as coisas diferentes não só falar
mas efetivamente tirar e assim não
esperar que as pessoas olhem pra você e
te reconheçam porque você está fazendo
algo diferente que também não é o
reconhecimento que te motiva é o seu eu
interior eu não quero que tinha chego
pra mim fala nosso obrigado pelo que
está fazendo
não quero mesmo ela talvez nem saiba o
quanto ela mexeu com a minha vida
naquele dia
saco mas eu sei que eu absorvi pra
caramba daquilo e obviamente a minha
maneira de pensar no mundo mudou por
conta disso o dia que eu percebi que
estava impactando a vida das pessoas
porque assim quando você tem um negócio
você paga o salário de todo mundo você
meio que poderia ser raso e falar pô eu
já estou mudando a vida dessa pessoa
porque ela consegue ver ela consegue
sustentar e satelital você meio que
falar tudo bem comigo estou sendo um bom
samaritano no mundo
pois bem o dia que eu percebi que a
minha relação de trabalho fugia da
esfera de trabalho e entrava no campo
social que mudava forma daquele cara ou
daquela menina olhar para a sociedade
olhar para assuntos como política o
assunto comum machismo agressão
sexualidade e começará a senhora dá umas
instaladas na cabeça é aquele cara que
nunca teve oportunidade de pensar nesses
assuntos realmente estava tomando uma
sacudida
foi um dia que um dos meninos chegou pra
mim e me puxou de lado e falou outros
trocar uma idéia com você na hora já
cheguei a me abaixar a cabeça e putz
cheguei cansado e achei que era coisa de
trabalho mas um probleminha do dia a dia
para resolver mas vamos lá
não minha filha veio conversar comigo eu
já falei pô de trabalho não é porque
está envolvendo a filha e fala cada dia
diz aí que tá pegando
não que ela tem 16 anos ela veio me
contar ontem que ela tem uma namorada
aí eu olhei me conhece vai entender mas
olhei pra ele e minha reação foi
simplesmente abrir um tremendo de um
sorriso tenta esconder a reação mas abri
meus dentes apareceram eu falei ai cara
como é que reagiu falou eu só queria te
agradecer porque o jeito com que eu
reagi com ela ontem eu devo aos três
anos que estou trabalhando aqui com você
e à maneira com que você aborda esse
tipo de assunto nosso dia a dia
estou feliz porque ela decidiu me
contasse com 16 anos eu estou feliz
porque eu levei ela no shopping passear
com a namorada dela ontem
estou feliz porque eu fui a primeira
pessoa para quem ela decidiu contar um
negócio tão importante na vida dela
quem é o que algum dia passou pela
situação da filha tem que contar para o
pai deve ter noção do quanto essa
então toda vai fazer a vida dessa menina
mais felizes daqui pra frente tudo isso
para dizer que ele imagina realmente
sentado aqui leva a ter uma galera que
têm pequenos projectos idéias
mirabolantes que podem não ter nada a
ver com dar uma sociedade eu faço óculos
de madeira não tem nada a ver com todo o
papo falando com vocês mas a maneira com
que você constrói seja um negócio seja
um projeto social seja um evento como
esse é capaz sim de transformar as
coisas do mundo
a gente tem que parar um pouco de olhar
para não mas olhar os dois lados da
vertente às vezes a gente tem coisas
globais que mudam quantitativamente sim
absurdos por aí existem projetos que
mudam a vida de muitas muitas pessoas
mas essas pequenas iniciativas locais
talvez um impacto em tantas pessoas
mas a gente consegue com certeza mudar
de forma muito mais humana e muito mais
efetiva a vida desse pessoal ea gente
espera que isso extrapola as fronteiras
de uma relação de trabalho certo
muito obrigado espero que tenha
contribuído com alguma coisa